fallout from the court's decision ruling
that abortion is no longer a
constitutional right in this country
more than half of women questioned in
the latest cbs news poll said that
overturning roe v wade this decision
we're talking about will make women's
lives worse but not all women feel that
way this morning we're hearing from a
diverse group of five kate feinberg
savannah ackerman k bryant abigail
galvin and amanda holliday bembridge
they all have deep feelings on abortion
and different feelings some support
abortion rights others oppose them
and the reactions are very fresh jan
crawford interviewed them shortly after
the supreme court announced its decision
i'm pro-choice i am pro-life pro-choice
i'm pro-choice i am against all forms of
violence and i consider abortion of
violence the court just overturned roe
versus wade a couple hours ago how are
you feeling right now in one word
concerned concerned just surreal for me
it's just more of the same i guess you
would say not surprised yeah not
surprised
i'm feeling hopeful i would say
frustrated
empathetic saddened
any of those what does that mean
personally i mean the fact that the
supreme court's overturned roe versus
wade i'm frustrated for the women that
won't be allowed to have the choice that
they are
being told what to do
by someone that doesn't know them or
their circumstances you can go to
different parts of the country and
different people want different things
so i actually think that the best way
to be able to minister to women and and
give them what they need is by having to
be at the state level they have more
control and are able to exercise more of
their choice what about you
i don't agree that
the states are
going to do a better job because
obviously many of the states have not
they are completely and outright banning
abortion for me personally
there's been this huge focus on legality
right it's never how are we helping the
women on the ground
what is the reason that people are
actually getting abortions i'm more
upset with the supreme court because i
feel like their decision that they've
made is actually not reflective of what
americans
largely polled um have indicated that
they believe do you any of you
you know have
girlfriends or friends or anyone that
you said like here's where we can find
common ground is it just either or
so actually i changed my stance on the
position when i was growing up so i came
from a very low income background i was
only told this narrative that
abortion is the way to go and anyone
who's against abortion doesn't like
women they don't support women
and that quite frankly isn't true you
reject the pro-life label
because it has come to mean so many
things and i think
again like
the super mainstream
movement is
super hypocritical i think there's
there's no other way to say it my
viewpoints don't come from religion
don't come from anything else it comes
from this fact that each human being is
distinct and
um
important and should be respected and
valued and so i'm against abortion in
the same way i'm against police
brutality and torturous acts within
prisons and
the death penalty it seems like one
thing you agree with
whether you're on
the left or the right or somewhere in
between
is that
a lot more should be done for women
and
children you're saying that the
anti-abortion movement could be doing
more
yeah and they should be and they should
have been the whole time and i am so
annoyed every time i hear that now the
real work begins because it's no
you should have been doing it what about
the
abortion rights movement the bigger
problem is that we can have all these
conversations but when you have white
christian male viewpoints making the
decisions at the end of the day or the
ones that are the loudest on tv in
social media then that is the rhetoric
that gets passed and we miss the points
of listening to all the other issues or
figuring out all the things that
surround this decision to support
maternal health or
prenatal postnatal care you're
anti-abortion do you think that the
movement should focus its efforts now on
changing the laws in states like
maryland or
the district of columbia or california
to make it more restrictive let's look
at all these
underlying issues that are the root
causes of why people are having to make
these decisions the danger in in pushing
for abortion is is just like you like
you don't think you have another option
like you're just told this is what you
do isn't that the opposite then
like if when you're saying if you feel
like the only option is abortion
but if you take that option away the
only option is life you're not giving a
choice
it will be decided on the state level uh
in that sense but i would say
that
but on an individual level
it takes that away from the mom or the
pregnant person well i would say
actually that if we're not focusing on
the legal issue of abortion then perhaps
we would be focusing our attention on
all these other supports i don't think
any one of us here is satisfied with
how politicians
don't do what we ask them to do they're
not listening to the problems so does
the idea that it is now going to be
politicians that get to decide
this issue
of abortion
scare you
um
honestly it doesn't scare me i try to
get involved in things that
reflect the way that i would like the
world to be
and i don't think that we consider
enough
how
what we do on our daily lives can affect
even the five of us here talking about
abortion today is that a positive thing
it is
talking about this because i was a
little concerned about coming here
and what i found is that there is a lot
of commonality in what we have to say
and i hope that
the viewers actually listen to it and
think about that and stop thinking about
okay
do you have access yes or no but what
about the other things those other
things are so much more important i'm
very impressed by each of these women
that i'm joined here today with i don't
like that like we've been pitted against
each other when i feel like we would be
more powerful working together i
understand that it's nuanced i
understand it's complex i feel like the
pro-life movement is not doing enough
and i feel like the pro-choice movement
is not doing enough
to
support women and i feel like that's
that's what's really important and
that's not getting heard i don't think
any of us think feel that
abortions are everyone's number one
choice right i think we would like to
create a world where that's not what
women want and women need and so looking
at it that way i think there's
there's common ground that we can
come together on to try and create more
of that kind of a world
now the women that we talked to are from
maryland and the washington dc area and
we had this interview planned for friday
morning before we knew that the court
was going to drop its decision over
turning roe versus wade so when some of
the women arrived at the hotel where we
spoke with them they had no idea that
roe was history
back to you guys that was a very
intelligent coherent conversation so we
do know it can be done but jane i like
the point you raise is it either or it's
so deeply political so deeply polarizing
where do we go from here
right and is consensus even possible
that is the question that is possible
and what are your thoughts jan you've
been covering this from the very
beginning and you've seen it up close
and personal you've talked to many
people on both sides of the issue almost
30 years of work yeah i mean it's
amazing
working we've come to this moment
well i mean i think that in many ways we
saw this on friday we had an idea that
this was going to happen right and yet
everyone was shocked on both sides like
this really did happen but i mean this
is part of an orchestrated campaign that
we're going to be talking about in the
eight o'clock hour to overturn roe
versus wade going back to 1974 the very
next year uh when when roe was creating
establishment establishing a
constitutional right to an abortion so
the the people in the anti-abortion
movement never gave up when they
suffered losses they regrouped and moved
on
all right jan crawford thank you very
much dan appreciate it